let's jump to this border stuff the
story's um the sub end of the story made
me laugh from fox news texas border
patrol agents discover stash houses
packed with nearly 100 illegal
immigrants but wait
none of the apprehended migrants were
wearing personal protective equipment
[Music]
why they brought that up
uh cbp said none of the migrants had
been wearing ppe agents provided them
ppe and they were medically screened
before being processed
yeah you think this was a babylon b cbp
has not said one of the migrants that's
a positive for coven 19. so
the story here should be that they found
a hundred illegal immigrants in stash
houses
but for some reason it's turned into
like ppe i guess
when you drive a narrative so hard
you got people distracted i mean look
that gabby potato thing when i when i
was out i know just i don't care i was
talking to this guy earlier and i was
like oh we're doing a new show it's like
mystery is true crying paranormal and he
was like oh so gabby petito and i was
like never
wait why not i wonder i'm curious why
not because for one
the story is about a missing woman
correct there are probably
300 missing women right now with tons of
news stories
secondly
we know that she's not alive
and that means the missing women who are
alive could use some news coverage so
perhaps we can find her or them while
they're still alive
also
this guy involved in the story
apparently there's evidence there was
you know cross domestic dispute stuff
and i'm like okay look
by all means report the story like you
report any other story but this
obsession with it that's like people
just started pushing all these stories
non-stop about what's going on this one
guy
and i'm like there's probably one of
these women serial killer
hitchhiker murderer
kidnapper this is a guy who was in a
domestic dispute where apparently in one
video she was like admitted to hitting
him and then he hit her and then who
knows what happened i don't know what
happened i'm not pretending to know what
happened but it's just one story that
they're giving all this attention to
and now here we are talking about i
don't care i think my favorite part
about that tim is seeing it with like
all the all the liberal media came out
and was like oh this is a missing white
woman syndrome and they're like
there's we have like every month or
every day 300 indigenous women go
missing and and they don't get the
attention i'm like you're the mainstream
media you're supposed to do that yeah
like wait a minute you have the platform
to do that they're the ones who don't do
it like the spider-man meme
and then brett who who works here made a
good point it was like didn't people
nearly burn down the country because a
black man was killed
yeah i'm like yeah this is just it's
it's it's the stupidest trash ever you
know to a certain degree i understand
what they're saying with missing white
women syndrome they're wrong though
because there are a bunch of missing
white women
there was a video of petito with her
nipples poking through her shirt that's
why it's a bunch of like young over
sexed guys pushing this narrative
i hear what you're saying yeah it's
disgusting but you can google search
missing women and find a bunch of but
that's why this one got no you can find
a bunch of other attractive young women
who are still alive and missing right
now with video of your nipples poking
through their shirts yes ian
yes well that's why i'm saying this is a
stupid story because she had some
instagram followers i think it was
awesome
it and then everyone else having nothing
better to do were like i guess i'll talk
about it too well one thing they'd
better do was take the spotlight off of
the afghanistan surrender oh yeah that
was like a week after that yeah
a lot of other stories i mean the border
crisis there's always some there's
always something this is what i mean
people love it because it's there's a
lot of young men in this country and a
lot of
missing relationships and you see a hot
girl
on tv it's like man does that draw
people's there are there are probably
hundreds of women of the same age and
same everything with videos maybe it's
like the right place at the right time
kind of thing oh it's like this one's
good sure sure it went viral on tick
tock and then the media was like we'll
roll with this story it was meaningless
and nonsensical so we got a real story
that i want to deviate from where we've
got stash houses full of illegal
immigrants and so i'm like i'm gonna
talk about that i don't i'm not gonna
talk about one missing person right when
there could literally i could talk about
other missing people how about all the
people being smuggled by human
traffickers there you go that's not the
news you gotta get a video on them
that's it man people like there's tons
of people what they see out of sight out
of my videos and go on put it on tick
tock just go on my twitter we got the
video
of all the people being smuggled yeah
smoking into the country i'd add record
numbers and
yeah
these kids are used
so some some smuggler will take a child
kidnap them and then they'll use it to
cross the border and say it's my child
and then as soon as they cross the
border they throw the kid and they walk
away
or they'll return the kid and give it to
somebody else and this kid has no idea
what's going on it's just being used as
a trafficking tool so that bleeding
hearts can be like the poor baby we
should make sure they're unified with
their parent and you're like that's not
the kid's parent dude that's a smuggler
trying to circumvent the law claiming
that kid is theirs
well we don't know that that's that
that's the problem when they talk about
child separation
they just make up oh trump was so evil
he separated parents from their you know
from their kids
how do we know those kids are related to
those old people we don't even even last
night time i was in roma texas and we
were documenting the uh the human
smugglers bringing in these these
nicaraguan migrants and there was one
man you could you could tell he had he
had a little little boy with him you
could tell that he wasn't the dead he
was grabbing them rough and when we had
the cameras out he was just acting
really frantic and and nervous it's like
we're watching in real time and you know
where's the media this is this is what
we're seeing at the board is impacting
brown and black lives um at a record
record number all the other the human
smuggling the trafficking like i said uh
july and august is the first time in
border patrol history that back-to-back
month over 200 apprehensions i mean you
can only imagine all the kids and i said
we witnessed it last night there was
this man just grabbing this kid almost
like manhandling them and i'm like
yo i mean look what's going on border
patrol is like we know we know we know
what's going on um they're that's not
that's not the dad um and that's
happening every single day and when
we're down there documenting the human
smuggling one thing that i always come
to mind is like this is just a little
bit part of a border that we're able to
see could you imagine the the rest of it
in arizona to new mexico and texas and
it's happening every day it's become
like the new normal oh they're like over
there that roma texas they're used to
having their wraps drop off kids um sex
traffic human smoke like i said they had
those those bracelets so you could you
could keep track with the proof of
purchase and that's not making the news
that's not making uh the headlines that
should be like our our top thing like we
actually have a humanitarian crisis at
our border i don't know if if the rest
of america just you know just because
it's the united states you know when
people think humanitarian crisis they
think oh they think yemen or the middle
east but we literally have one here at
the southern border and it's happening
every single day it's happening right
now what we're speaking to some extent
like people are like desensitized to it
like since like
the drum was being beaten since like 20
whatever 2017 like the first like trump
puts kids in cages that was the first
time when people were like oh there's an
actual crisis at the bar and then from
there it was like today it's like oh it
got dropped you see a drop it's like
it's like different group of people back
then it was mexico now it's like what
haitians and i was speaking to a border
patrol agent and these uh in these
border facilities right there they're in
these rooms what they that they call
pods and these pods they're only meant
for like eight migrants at a time yeah
border patrol was telling me there's
like 400 people in these eight-person
pods each stacked on against each other
like 400 in each room where they're only
meant for eight like he said they're
people literally sleeping on top of each
other like he was texting me all this
all this information he's like hey with
these haitians it's even worse and that
a lot of those haitian males
they came with young like young children
and he's like we're we're trying to
break them up you know from the the real
falls or not but they're like we there's
so many migrants we there's just not
enough that we could do and even even
nbc news put out a report last month
that those migrants are being sexually
assaulted
in those facilities there's no way to
keep track of them the new york times
put out a report last month that one uh
one out of every three migrant children
released into united states they lose
track of
biden was smuggling kids across the
united states remember that story nope
there's a video of it and that stuff
just disappears
and the funny thing is joe biden's
approval writing didn't take a hit from
it nope can i see one of those
wristbands well let's let's let's let's
can i have one of those
are you giving can i have one of those
to keep thanks man
this is this is it if you want to
remember i want to remember this
and this is just like the reason why i
kind of collect them and kind of bring
them is just to kind of show the kind of
american audience like this is happening
in real time and they say you know on
these braces they say entregas which
means delivered and they actually treat
these migrants like almost like an
amazon product like a shipment so two
things either happen either the magnets
have already paid so they'll be you know
they'll cross and you know they'll be
released into united states or two is if
they didn't pay
um their full price then they'll be
essentially becoming indentured servants
and slaves here and they'll say
yeah and then you can see like the
little kids always have these bracelets
on their ankles so they can't like
easily come off um so it's just
it's it's it's crazy to see you see it
in in in person and that it's like it's
literally happening in the united states
and one border patrol source told me
that the cartels are making up to 14
million a day just off human smuggling
not even counting their where does the
money come from
it's the cocktail
yeah
well the cartoons are really rents have
are in the cartoon no the the cartoons
are really smart is when they get
connected with these migrates these huge
caravans is
they all the majority of like the
central americans they already have
family in the state so what the cartels
do is they they connect they get
connected with the family in the states
and they make them pay the five thousand
six thousand seven thousand dollars for
that fee so it's very well organized and
the people back in the state where do
they get that money from
the the the family in that already
already lives here in the united states
oh okay yeah like so they send their
money back to them yeah so it's like i
was entering a couple salvadoran
families that like they had to pay a
coyote like seven thousand dollars to
get like their cousins here to the
border so like the the the cartels are
smart they'll get connected with the
family members back in the us they'll
make them pay the fee because they have
the money and that's how they kind of
organize and get here like i said and if
they don't pay the fee they essentially
become indentured servants and that's
something that me and sonic got to see
firsthand we just um you know spent like
two months in southern california
documenting these cartels who are coming
into that area they're starting up
illegal marijuana growth so usually when
you know when people hear illegal you
know marijuana girls it's like oh what's
what's the big deal it's just pot it's
just like two hippie dudes in the middle
of nowhere listening to reggae but
what's happening is that these cartels
found out that in california it's so
rural these deserts they start up
illegal marijuana operations and then
they'll smuggle the the migrants from
south texas and force them to work those
marijuana grows and they'll arm them
because out there they're having
literally cartel battles between other
cartels and other magic groups thanks
for checking out this clip from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to see the
full show come back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments and super chat and we actually
will read your comments on the show
don't forget to like share subscribe and
if you want exclusive members only
content segments you can't get anywhere
else go to timcast.com become a member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you